avec marie-anne chazel thierry lhermitte
gérard jugnot
[Applaudissements]
avec jean-marie pour lier josiane
balasko yves lecoq avec pierre tchernia
yves duteil et patrick coutin patrick
hutin lance bonjour à toutes et à tous
bienvenue sur antenne 2 deuxième rendez
vous avec l'académie des neuf avec les
neuf académiciens qui nous est présenté
il ya quelques minutes et puis deux
candidats parmi les deux candidats une
personne que vous connaissez
elle était là hier elle est sortie
vainqueur du match bonjour anne vous
allez bien vous changez vous allez
revenir demain nous allons savoir et
tout à l'heure j'aimerais que votre
voisin se présente il s'agit de gérard
kivu gerin gérard coutelier je suis
cadre commercial et je viens de nice
mais de nice sur la côte d'azur dans les
alpes-maritimes
paris face à nice qui de paris ou de
nice à l'emporter nous le saurons dans
30 minutes environ 12,7 30 minutes
agréables de divertissement de jeu le
premier de ces jeux le voici des neuf
cases
[Musique]
alors les 9-15 vous avez vu l'émission
hier bien entendu vous le savez il
suffit pour l'un des deux candidats
d'arriver à tracer une ligne en
diagonale en verticale ou à
l'horizontale ça n'a pas d'importance
gérard vous disposerez d'une croix pour
le faire quand avoue anne luron le petit
rond qui étaient là avec vous hier matin
l'objectif concernant l'académie de 9,6
bien sûr c'est de gagner un maximum 2 à
2 le à deux c'est cette mode et que
voici voici le billet de mille à 2 me
rendais compte la fortune qui se trouve
sur mon pupitre est extraordinaire cette
sorte une qui permettra aux candidats
vendredi de participer à une vente aux
enchères super avec la complicité nos
académiciens et de gagner pourquoi pas
une voiture un téléviseur mais otoscope
un rond de serviette
nous verrons tout cela vendredi à sable
pour l'instant je peux pas vous le dire
premier jeu qui commence tirage au sort
je vais demander à mme de pile ou face
face
la pièce était toujours pas trouvé ses
fastes décidément vous avez beaucoup de
chance qu'elle est l'académicienne vous
choisissez pour ce premier jeu je vais
choisir jean marie premier jean-marie
proslier monsieur premier comment allez
vous depuis hier de mieux en mieux ça se
voit jean-marie attila roi des huns et
lyon 8 pas peur à 965 sont morts de
façon on ne souffle pas sinon c'est
savoir de façon identique laquelle de
façon identique à tigery oui mais une
façon un peu original un peu original le
chrono est partie 22 secondes
vingt-et-une on s'est tous au rebut 20
communes sont étouffés s'était pas tout
à fait boire même en mangeant non
sazy ils sont morts en effet dans leur
lit mais comment je crois que j'ai
accepté la réponse politique qu'est ce
qu'il faisait
chacun de leur côté bien entendu je
faisais l'amour at il un élément huit
sont morts au cours d'ébats sexuels
c'était la réponse que j'attendais sur
votre écran vous allez voir apparaître
d'abord 10.10 à 2 pour vous chers âne et
un rond c'est à dire le début d'une
ligne gérard que faites vous avec qui
vous voulez vous jouer avec josiane
balasko tu avec josiane balasko josiane
voici la question
le boudin non vous n'êtes pas pour moi
non pas du tout désagréable non pas du
tout mais c'est simplement le hasard du
questionnaire qui fait que je tombe sur
le boudin le goût d'un le nez et le
giron sont partis d'un élément très
courant de la maison lequel mon chien
j'ai un chien très courant c'est un
élément courant de la maison qui font
partie de l' architecture de la maison
qui est indispensable non ce n'est pas
la porte
les escaliers bonne réponse en effet de
josiane balasko la ligne ne sera pas
facile à établir and que faites-vous ont
choisi pierre tchernia vous choisissez
pierre tchernia soyez le bienvenu pierre
qui revient vous nous parliez tout à
l'heure de votre rentrée sur intel de ce
sera pour ce soir voici la question au
japon pierre grande politique est en
effervescence
l'un des leaders de l'opposition a même
déclaré qu'un ministre en activité comme
est un tel acte
cela relève d'une attitude politique du
gouvernement tout entier tout ça parce
que le monsieur le ministre était sur
noise mans photographié à votre avis
qu'est ce qu'il faisait sur cette photo
le ministre
est ce qu'ils aiment et ce qu'ils aient
la même chose qu'eux at-il à rodez
non mais il a été surpris par un
photographe accroupi
oui la bonne réponse bien jouer c'est
très très bien joué et je suppose
maintenant ans gérard que vous allez
choisir la case numéro un c'est-à-dire
marie-anne chazel
c'est indispensable si vous voulez
contre et votre adversaire
marianne boris karloff qui a incarné le
monstre de frankenstein au cinéma passé
cinq heures à se faire maquiller
que faisait-il pour pouvoir aller de la
cabine de maquillage jusqu'au plateau de
tournage sans risquer de serre peur non
oui mais comment qu'est ce qu'il faisait
non
comment c'était tabou
oui c'est la réponse qu'il se met à
votre ligne s'envole pour l'instant mais
il y avait d'autres possibilités
alors que faites vous j'ai choisi yves
lecoq choisissez yves lecoq yves le
président mexicain ignacia colons forte
fut déposée et condamnés à l'exil pour
la révolution de 1858 mais pourquoi
peut-on dire que ce fut un bel exemple
d'autocritique
top chrono 30 secondes il avait alors
pourquoi vous êtes prêt de la réponse il
fut déposée et condamnés à l'exil quelle
est l'originalité de cette condamnation
je m'habille presque donné la réponse il
était oui qu'il avait déclenché la
révolution lui même et qui s'était
lui-même fait alors voilà sur le gong il
reste une seconde c'est la répétition
s'est imposé tout seul et s'est condamné
lui-même
nous disposons de dix questions pour ce
jeu voici la 6e et c'est à qui c'est
avoue gérard alors on peut voir avec
voici que faites-vous à prix coûtant
vous allez prendre votre patrick coutin
c'est bien jouer patrick qui a dit
récemment c'est le premier championnat
du monde que je rate depuis huit ans à
sportif en tweed
bien sûr c'est un mec qui fait du vélo
attendez vous voulez vous réfléchir à ce
que vous dites c'est un sportif qui fait
du vélo oui c'est bernard c'est une
question tout à fait d'actualité puisque
ça se passait la semaine dernière au
cours des championnats du monde
et qu'est ce que je vois là je vois à
eux y une ligne formée de trois croix ce
qui signifie cher gérard que c'est vous
qui l'emportait sous les
applaudissements depuis les
félicitations et les tongs
les voici 30 à 2 pour anne mais ça va
s'arranger rassurez-vous 30 à 2 pour
vous et la prime de 100 à 2
supplémentaires
je vous félicite le match est bien
partie qui sera là demain
patientons patiente on les compte donc
son fait voici maintenant le deuxième
des jeux avec le dernier des neuf
[Musique]
le dernier délai fête venez avec moi
nous allons voir pierre tchernia
qu'hélène aux invités qui va nous parler
de sa rentrée ce soir sur antenne 2
pierre qu'est ce qui va se passer ce
soir nous reprenons mardi cinéma cette
émission dont le titre est prémonitoire
puisque elle passe le mardi je trouve
que cette saison même si oui elle aurait
pu passer du mercredi au jeudi et ce
soir nous aurons bien sûr nos invités la
caméra cachée que fait notre ami jacques
rouland des reportages des extraits de
films nouveaux et le film de la soirée
c'est pile ou face de mon sur pile ou
face pile ou face mais c'est un film
très réussi de robert enrico dans lequel
s'affrontent deux grands comédiens
michel serrault et philippe noiret et
d'ailleurs dans les semaines qui
viennent
il ya des films qui me paraissent
intéressantes on va avoir un aperçu du
programme de l'année
eh bien écoutez je nous allons nous
allons présenter un mauvais fils le film
de claude sautet qui est le chevalier
dire un mauvais film non mais qui ont
dit non un mauvais fils le film de
claude sautet qui est le seul film qu'il
ait tourné avec patrick dewaere et qui a
été un des grands rôles de patrick
dewaere et le public s'est beaucoup
plaint que depuis la mort de patrick on
n'est pas passés de films intelligents
donc que nous aurons plaisir d'offrir un
mauvais fils et puis il y a une semaine
de vacances de tavernier
il y à une reprise du petit baigneur de
mon ami robert dhéry il y à mon ami
flicka qui est un film très familiale
est très jolie l'histoire d'une une
pouliche et d'un petit garçon dans les
plaines américaines enfin bref et le
compte du nombre de films que vous avez
présenté à la télé depuis quelques
offres pour vos amis vous savez je fais
la télévision depuis si longtemps qu' il
faudrait les archéologues pour parler de
moi même pas des critiques merci
vous allez jouer vous serez d'ailleurs
le premier candidat à notre jeu le
dernier de 9,7 à qui c'est avoue anne
alors voici la question pierre tchernia
la règle du jeu vous la connaissez nous
posons des questions aux académiciens
les uns après les autres
le dernier qui restent en jeu gagne et
fait gagner son candidat
la question pierre lavoie 6 quel est le
point commun entre un orgue et un
turfiste le point commun entre un organe
turfistes bracine twingo bah oui bien
sûr c'est la bonne réponse c'est la
bonne réponse et je dois dire chez ram
que je vous ai fait un petit cadeau
puisque je rappelle que vous avez la
possibilité de refuser la réponse de
notre académicien à titre exceptionnel
joue cinq ados je n'en ferai pas d'autre
donc dix points supplémentaires
gérard c'est à vous maintenant est une
question que nous posons un yves duteil
un point commun entre une oie et une
porte n'a pas de jardin porte ces fameux
bail à lebbeke de cannes non non non non
nous une loi une porte le pen
non mon cher yves duteil c'est trop tard
c'est trop tard vous faisait
pratiquement 10 la réponse ou le temps
c'était le parent tout simplement le pas
de l'oie le ces deux pas de la force
oui je ne vous demande pas si vous
acceptez aussi vous refusez la réponse
puisque réponse et il n'y a pas eu à
nova tunes droit soit ouverte ou fermée
exactement c'est patrick coutin anne
voici la question pour patrick boutin
c'est toujours un point commun bien sûr
entre une carotte est une vedette assez
facile à une carotte une vedette
prennent racine tous les deux non c'est
pas ça
trois secondes une carotte une vedette
patrick c'est trop les fans vous avez
des phares on venait à londres on vous
met à l'ombre on était à la casse de
patrick utage suis désolé pour vous ou
moi enfin passons tout de suite à
marie-anne chazel qui se trouve tout là
haut pour vous gérard un point commun
encore marianne entre une gare et le
cuisine une gare une cuisine et un point
commun évident alors une réponse
mais ya pas de dry dans une cuisine n'y
est pas rien du tout et c'est terminé
cher mari à l'eau du fait de la gare et
le buffet de la cuisine
il ya aussi un chef de gare un chef de
cuisine j'aurais pu accepter c'est
acquis maintenant on marque pas beaucoup
de points on ne marque pas beaucoup de
points thierry lhermitte latham et
bientôt la question à vous poser parce
que jusqu'à présent ça voyant gestion
entre une église et une forêt merde on
avait le bois les bleus boire et c'est
pas évident c'est pas évident on est
bien dans une forêt ya des troncs
d'arbres dans une église ya des trous
aussi énervant c'est une très bonne
question sur mer 6 de reconnaître qu'il
s'agissait d'une bonne question
dites moi ça s'éclaircit sur notre sur
notre écran mais pour l'instant vous ne
marquez pas beaucoup de points qui joue
avec gérard jugnot d'accord c'est vous
gérard gérard face à gérard si le point
commun m
c'est très compliqué un plombier est un
chanteur un plombier un chanteur non tu
es dans le le tube alors vous acceptez
bien entendu je n'ai même posé vous
posez la question tellement c'était
simple vous acceptez vous marquez dit à
deux supplémentaires ce qui vous fait 40
à 2 ânes c'est à vous maintenant
jean-marie premier point commun entre
l'autoroute un pantalon pour ce facile
la bretelle la bretelle bien sûr le
projet avec l'autoroute alors faire sur
c'est ce que je dis est tout à coral je
vous rappelle pas d'accord vous appuyez
sur la semaine pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
contestation possible
jean marie poli et reste avec nous
josiane balasko joue maintenant avec
gérard le point commun entre cyrano et
pinocchio d'accord tout à fait d'accord
c'est la bonne réponse ni yves lecoq
avec anne le point commun entre un
pêcheur est une machine à écrire
atomique par doc la touche
vous êtes d'accord c'est en effet la
touche les tout petits pêcheurs à la
ligne électrique ou en sommes-nous là il
reste en notre compagnie pierre tchernia
à qui je pose un autre point commun tout
de suite je le pense pas j'en ai plus
alors je vous propose un autre jeu tout
simplement lequel des trois pièces les
écureuils remplacent les iroquois en
australie s'agit-il d'un dessin animé
inédit de tex avery que vous connaissez
peut-être je parle du dessin animé du
renouvellement d'un parc d'hélicoptère
ou d'un message codé de la deuxième
guerre mondiale
les écureuils remplacent les iroquois en
australie disons les hélicoptères les
hélicoptères vous acceptez la réponse
c'est la bonne en effet les hélicoptères
je suis jugnot oui je vous réveille ça
va l'eau à très bien bon monsieur jugnot
vous allez jouer avec mademoiselle and
we une faîtière est ce une tuile une
foraine en patois docs ou une intrigante
une faîtière n'en profitez pas pour
réfléchir est une tuile une foraine en
patois docs ou une intrigante de l'huile
vous dites une tuile qu'en pensez vous
vous êtes d'accord vous êtes bien c'est
une tuile excellente réponse on a parlé
d'un de départager le premier journal
européen futile belges allemands ou
italiens allemands ou italiens
jean-marie une réponse un des trois
obame allemand allemand a eu du mal à
sonner vous sonnez pourquoi à votre avis
la réponse c'est plus prendre ça plutôt
italien ou penser italien donc jean
marie dit allemand vous dites italien la
réponse c'est belge donc eu raison de
mecs personnes
c'était le yéti ningen c'est à dire le
nouveau journal au revoir monsieur
premier merci beaucoup d'être venu
josiane balasko vous jouez avec anne
maintenant combien de personnes de plus
de 60 ans y at il en france 13% 17% 21%
17% 17% vous souvenez vous n'êtes pas
d'accord
à votre avis la réponse est davantage
17% c'était la bonne réponse
josiane vous ne gagnez pas de la douane
en revanche josiane balasko reste en
notre compagnie yves lecoq une
pantalonnade est une expression qui
désigne une scène d habiller qui vient
du personnage italien pantalon ou qui
signifie que l'on boîte l'arrière que
l'on botte l'arrière-train de quelqu'un
c'est l'arrière train vous n'êtes pas
d'accord
pourquoi cela vienne du personnage de
comédie italienne pantalon excellente
réponse 10 à 2 supplémentaires pour vous
enfin monsieur le coq alors pas ça
s'éclaircit pas mal il reste une ligne
on aurait pu faire le premier jeu ainsi
regarder la cette ligne nous allons
maintenant demander a ajouté gérard je
suis là parce que je vous vois
disparaître comme c'est avoue gérard
nous allons maintenant vous proposer un
plus ou moins vous allez voir nous
allons nous allons arriver je le pense à
vous départager on s'accroît davantage
dans les départements du loiret ou de
paris loiret non je parle donc vous la
réponse et le loiret c'est la bonne
réponse en effet 13,8 pour cent tel
instant de votre cassette est un des
plus grands la parole paris se dépeuple
- 11,2 pour cent par an une autre
question maintenant josiane balasko
c'est à vous la voix si vous jouez avec
gérard quelle religion rassemble le plus
de fidèles le bouddhisme ou l'hindouisme
josiane une réponse tout de suite s'il
vous plaît le bouddhisme
êtes vous d'accord vous n'avez pas sonné
donc vous
à vous sonnez donc vous dites
l'hindouisme c'est vous qui avez raison
en effet merci josiane l'hindouisme 472
millions le bouddhisme 185 millions de
membres pierre jouer avec anne pierre
quel pape était plus jeune quand il fut
élu jean paul ii ou benoît 9
benoît nov benoît meuf êtes vous
d'accord vous avez tout à fait raison
benoît mais fut élu il avait le saviez
pierre 12 ans c'est ça il avait 12 ans
environ j'ai quelques homophones
maintenant pour vous départager monsieur
jugnot à monsieur tchernia alors assez
jugnot qui reste c'est juste
il est au troisième monsieur jugnot s'il
vous plaît blé moulu et peintre du 15e
siècle blé moulu et peintre du xvème
siècle il faut il faut dire quoi bein
homophones il faudrait penser exemple
cochon su mais philosophe anglais bacon
voilà je vous dis blé moulu partir du
15e siècle vous me dire oui froment
bonnes réponses
pierre tchernia boue et faute de liaison
la pop ait eu à huer une faute de
liaison alors l'homophobe allophones
entre la peau merci perçu en agaçait de
laisser merci pierre tchernia
il fallait répondre cuir la fourrure
cuir et vous faites erreur qui était
également c'est gérard jugnot s'est
acquis de jouer maintenant avec gérard
c'est avoue gérard contre gérard allez
vous gagnez 100 à 2 supplémentaires nous
allons le savoir tout de suite voici
homophones pour vous gérard oui
champions et catastrophe boursière à
crac'h l'accepter vous c'est la bonne
réponse soldats supplémentaires et le
dernier des neuf maintenant c'est
important vous le savez c'est très très
important c'est le rond de serviette la
voiture voici le dernier jeu les neuf à
la cote
les l'afa la cote nous avons interrogé
le public qui se trouve présent avec
nous sur les chances respectives de nos
neuf académiciens de répondre à une
question bien précise et ainsi nous
avons plus étalé nous avons pu établir
décote
la première question qui a été posée la
suivante qui parmi ses acolytes et
académicien pourrait nous citer sans
sourciller et en un temps donné
cette station thermale française c'est
la question anne c'est à vous de
commencer je vous rappelle que vous ne
disposez que de 90 à 2 c'est important
le à deux vous le verrez vendredi en
revanche gérard dispose de 310 à 2 anne
avec qui vous voulez vous jouer
voici les cotes qui apparaissent les
voici
et combien misez-vous alors cette
station thermale française
oui je vais mise
50 à 2 sur pierre tchernia 50 à 2 sur
pierre tchernia 5 x 8 40 ce qui vous
permettrait éventuellement de gagner 400
à 2 supplémentaires ce qui sauverait la
situation voulez vous me donner ses 52
vous allez disposer d'un certain temps
pour me donner cette station thermale
française vous êtes vraie attention
top chrono c'est parti quand ce n'est
pas au bout alors cette station de
dufilho dans un monologue parlant de
vichy en dix ans tous nos grands
cerveaux ont soigné leur sous leur foi
vichy une noria vichy on y à
contrexéville 2 qu'un second
aix-les-bains aix les bains
ja
vittel by seconde vie tel y'a evian
evian ya badouard trois secondes une ans
est non et non pierre tchernia et non et
non j'ai une liste très complète de
toutes les stations thermales française
ex en province aix les bains
allevard-les-bains amélis argelès soluce
ax les thermes à bagnères de bigorre et
on va ainsi jusqu'à la fin et là c'est
la wii
hélas vous aviez tenté 50 à 2 que j'ai
là que je conserve vous tentiez 400 m2
supplémentaires avec la côte de pierre
tchernia 40 à 2 pour vous on ne sait pas
brillant du tout que faites-vous
maintenant gérard la question qui a été
posée au public est la suivante qui
parmi ces deux académiciens peut nous
donner cinq noms propres représentants
des unités de mesure
alors attention cinq noms propres
représentants des unités de mesure voici
les cotes sont là actuellement sur votre
écran
que faites vous vous avez une petite
avance mais je me répète cette grande
serviette ou la voiture essayer de
gagner un maximum 2 à 2 je vais miser
100 à 200 sur gérard jugnot 100 ha de
vous j'ai même pas compris a répété dont
la cote est de 10 contre 1 c'est à dire
vous tentez mille à 2 supplémentaires
nous sommes bien d'accord cher gérard
jugnot
oui je vous devais me donnait cinq noms
propres qui correspondent à des unités
de mesure en exemple s'il vous plaît
bien volontiers je vous dis on perd
monsieur ampère et lampert l'écouté
alors c'est parti
monsieur what we bonnes réponses un
monsieur joule monsieur joue le deuxième
réponse
monsieur en perd ça compte pas non merci
e
[Musique]
kilowatts elle-même 10 secondes monsieur
volts
monsieur volts bonnes réponses plus que
deux
je retrouve monsieur monsieur ans trône
nom gérard jugnot
j'avoue que ce n'est pas facile du tout
mais il y avait mille à 2 à gagner vous
ne les avez pas gagné vous allez
d'ailleurs me donner la somme que vous
avez misé les réponses y avait en perd
coulon henry hertz joule que vous aviez
brillamment cité d'ailleurs le public
était debout dans la salle weber quel
vin newton homme pascal volts watts en
oublie sans doute il n'y avait pas cinq
gérard jugnot s'est peut-être pas votre
spécialité non ah oui c'est ça et
comment est-il le père noël ils étaient
une centaine à 2 c'est à vous maintenant
anne on a demandé au public qui parmi
ces académiciens pour éventuellement
nous donner quatre noms communs de
poissons commençant par la lettre m j'ai
l'impression que c'est plus facile que
la question précédente
anne combien mise et vous vous avez
toujours un retard à rattraper a deux
sur gérard jugnot alors 20 20 à 2 sur
gérard jugnot 2 x 4,8 pouvez vous me
donner vos vins de ses looks et gérard
jugnot
j'ai encore pas entendu la question mais
je vous la donne et quatre noms communs
de poissons commençant par la lettre m
des poissons m me com merci c'est ça des
poissons le chrono est partie 28
secondes
les nus l'un la murène la murène bonnes
réponses
le verlan le poisson on ne souffle pas
on ne souffle pas le mérou parce que
l'enjeu est important
un quatrième poisson là mourut bravo
gérard jugnot
vous êtes le père noël vous êtes un
grand spécialiste en poissons aussi on
vienne ne remarquez il y en avait
d'autres y avait la menthe marlins le
mérou la cité la morue le maquereau que
j'aurais pu gagner encore on a oublié de
citer mais enfin il fallait en citer 4
c'est à dire que on va voir apparaître
maintenant sur votre totalisateur un
gain supplémentaire qui n'est pas à
négliger
anne à vous maintenant de prendre votre
revanche nous sommes bien d'accord la
question qui a été posée est la suivante
10 différentes courses en athlétisme
course de vitesse course de vitesse
prolongée de demi fond et de demi-fond
prolongé
en fait je vais demander 10 distance qui
se pratique en athlétisme les cotes
apparaissent maintenant sur votre écran
and combien misez vous d'agir or c'est à
gérard parent dont gérard combien
misez-vous eh bien je vais miser 200 à 2
sur patrick coutin 200 à 2 sur patrick
coutin patrick coutin je vous écoute
distances différentes en athlétisme le
110 mètres le 110 mètres m 400 m 800 m
le 1000 m le 15 100 m oui le 5000 m le 5
mai type le 10000 m le marathon et 10
500 finissent à bien nous applaudissons
félicitations et un spécialiste a
réfléchi
mais rapidement les comptes et nous
allons conclure 4000 le 10 à 2 pour
gérard qui sans aucun problème sera là
demain d'autres compagnies quant à vous
anne vous pourrez les dépenser vos 820
de vendredi au cours des enchères des
neuf je vous souhaite un très bon
appétit à vendredi yann adoma gérard bon
appétit à vous toutes et à vous tous et
à demain 12h10
[Musique]